Did do days.
If you had a beef with somebody,
you didn't go on fucking social
media and talk a bunch of bullshit.
You fucking walked up to the
person and you said, hey,
here I am and what the fuck, let's let's
deal with this. Let's talk about it,
talk it out. But now you got people
buying followers and do another.
It's just that it's,
you know,
it's just the most toxic environment in
a lot of ways and it's a shame because
it could be used and that's
why I never post negative shit.
I tried to use the platform, you know,
make lighter shit and not have a stickup.
You asked this too many people that do
even the plant based Vegan thing and
everything's so fucking serious.
I'm like,
you might reach more people if you
lightened up, you know, like stripes.
Lighten up Francis, you
know? Yeah, I think so.
If you say you eat me,
how
well you did write a book
called meat is for pussies.
Tell you how that came about
and actually I got attacked.
I'm going to tell you something else you
want to talk about destroying people.
I got attack more by the
Vegan feminists for that book.
Fucking tried to destroy me.
They will everybody,
cause I wrote posts now first
of all. And then she, uh,
she went on a blog and call
me a massage and I said, yeah,
like massages the but you know,
call me and misogynistic scumbag and
in fucking piece of shit and all this.
So I just had, I just wrote, Hey, any of
you ladies that bought this book for the,
for the fellows and it helped them please
fucking Holler at this fucking woman
and tell some they shut
her fucking blog down.
And then she called me a maniac
and I said, let's call Germania.
She sent people on her the way she
sent people in. Yeah. But dig this.
And then I said,
we have,
we have a saying on the streets in New
York back in the day, don't start nothing.
There won't be none. I said,
you know, but the thing was,
I'm going to tell you how to book title
came back cause it was a woman, actually,
Karen Renaldi from a Harper Collins wave.
And what happened was, uh, I was
trained in at crunch, Aaron, uh, uh,
Dragos Winooski is my trainer and he's
gotten me through all my fucking Iron
Mans, everything else, fucking
broken up, person injuries, all this.
So I'm where I was working at
crunch and training with him.
And then another person,
a friend of mine or the five
points guys used to be there,
you would see them all.
They had a ring on the second floor.
So this guy was doing pad work and I'm
telling him, Hey, you know, listen man,
you got a fight coming up man. Get on
the chlorophyll, get on the wheat grass,
get on,
you know,
eat as much recovery foods as you can
that's going to fight inflammation.
So some fucking Momma Luke with
fucking 1980s tiger striped pants,
fucking fucking, you know, he, he,
he just took everything out of
context and then he's like, yeah,
fucking people that don't we me a
full sees, you know, I'm like, Yo,
you got like 50 pounds on me,
but if you want to put some head gear and,
and get in the ring, I'll oblige you. He's
like, what? I said, I don't eat meat bro.
And then the funny shit with the whole
book title was it was going to be called
the grow green road to health,
fitness and longevity.
And my business partner, Todd
Erwin goes, mother Fucker,
who are you doctor eyes? Nobody wants
to hear that book from you, your job,
blood clot, Joseph singer from the Cro
mags, they want, and then I post it,
they will. And then I said, yeah. I
said, yeah, this motherfucker was like,
you know,
same fucking people that don't eat me
to push these on like motherfucker,
that dude ain't probably ain't seen
his dick and fucking 10 years he was
overweight and all this shit like that.
Motherfuckers to pussy. And he's like, Yo,
you know what? Throw it back in his face.
And I was like, I don't know man. That's,
you know, that's, you know, pretty
fuckable statement. He said, do it, do it.
So we released so right away to fucking
emails and the text of the city of the
vegans, Yo, that's how we
started. And then we, uh,
our agent Dan,
we got hooked up with this guy,
Dan from ICM. He's like, Ma, my business
partner in the Hamptons. He's like,
Yo, that book is fucking dope man. I think
we could get a deal. We did in a week.
He have four offers. So
you wrote it first. Yeah,
I wrote it first and we put it out.
So it was the thought process behind
widen that you just had a lot of shit in
your head just wanting to get out.
Yeah.
Well I studied writing under Robert McKee,
so I wrote my memoir first.
Interesting. Yeah. Story. I fucking that
guys like my guru for writing. I took,
I took the story seminar twice. He's
fucking amazing. I mean, Brian Cox,
his portrayal of him in,
in fucking,
in a adaptation fucking brilliant spot on.
So,
and you know, I, I actually became
friends with Robert. Mr. McKay. I would,
he smoked like crazy realize. Yeah. He
smoked cigarettes like a fucking Cim.
Not a writers do, man. Yeah,
but not during the class.
So when he had the breaks,
he would fucking do like two or
three cigarettes. I said, you know,
my friend has an organic green tea extract
company and the Polyphenols in that
is going to counteract all your
fucking smoking shit that you're doing.
So I gave him five bottles and
then every time he would come,
he would have his people call Yo,
you know that guy fucking Macau and get
them to bring me some more of that green
tea shit. Did he quit smoking? I
don't know. Have you seen him in,
the problem is it gives them
a charge. Some uh, you know,
a nootropic charge fires up your brain.
Yeah, it's a smoke a cigarette man.
I smoked like crazy. I used to smoke
Kools in lock up and shit like, you know,
cause that's what they give you in
Spofford. And uh, and when I went upstate,
it was cools,
quit.
I quit cause I started boxing in lockup
and they would have us run this fucking
hill called suicide hill and I would
be fucking puking. And I was like,
I gotta quit fucking smoking.
So I quit smoking. Be,
they used to do smoker fights in lockup.
So if you had a beef with somebody,
you went into this rec room was
explained smokers to people,
they don't know what
that smoker fights means.
You just have a beef with somebody and
you could just throw on the gloves and,
and go at it.
And as long as it's like reasonably within
20 pounds of weight difference, like,
yeah.
You know,
although in lockup I saw
people much bigger people,
a fighting much smaller people in
some of them guys. I mean I would,
I was not good.
I got,
I would fight the black dudes and they
would just beat the shit out of me,
but that would just keep coming back.
You know, I'm Irish, I don't quit man.
I was and, and then, you know,
I learned more of the
sweet science and you know,
went into the navy and so you quit
smoking just for boxes? Yeah, I quit.
I quit smoking. Uh, yeah for that, for
that reason. But when I was locked up,
I didn't quit almost to the end because
towards the end of your sentence,
they allow you to go home because they
want to reintegrate you back with your
family or whatever. And I never grew up
with my mom, so they would send us home.
So we would take the carton in the
cigarettes and open it up very carefully,
open up the cellophane,
carefully slide the cellophane down and
put joints inside the cigarette pack,
slide it back up, glue it closed
the cart and the cigarettes.
And as how we would get to
weed back from the visits.
Cause I wasn't smoking weed coming back
out and nobody's asked. That was no,
I'm like, no, thank
you. So that, you know,
so that was the process. And um, you
know, so that's why, that's why I quit.
But that's the book came,
I had a lot of shit,
a lot of demons inside of
me from what happened to me,
me and my two brothers, uh,
was,
you know,
pretty severely abused in all kinds of
ways in his foster home, physically,
mentally, sexually abused by
the older kids. In the home,
it was fucked up and I never told anybody,
but that was always something.
No matter how much I lived as a monk for
two years, or Hari Krishna Monk, nothing,
uh,
cure that fucking anger that was inside
of me that I had toward these people for
what they did to me. And the secret of
like, Yo, it's fucked up to say like, Yo,
you're just do from the streets.
You had knife fights were Puerto Ricans.
I got shot with a 22 and forest parks
on angel. Does that get us there?
And then to try to say, Yo, this
motherfucker Molesta me is WWE.
It took a lot out of me too.
And nobody knew it because
they never talked about it.
And I took my keys class and that was the
turning point because I went up to him
and I was writing a script at the time
based on what happened to me in the
foster home, the kids, uh, in
the screenplay we based, uh,
what, what happened to me, uh, in,
in my younger, uh, period of my life.
And, um, I never told anybody what
happened. I would just avoid that.
But then when I wrote,
I started writing the book and I
was taking his class and between,
uh, you know, parts of his
thing, when you went on a break,
you could walk up to Robert Mckean,
see, ask them questions. So I said,
Mr Makia as far as a protagonist who was
abused as a kid and he stopped me right
there and he said, listen,
stop. Right Day send McGowan.
Everybody uses it. It's a cliche,
you know, abusive children,
uh,
to develop empathy for characters we
could otherwise not give a fuck about.
It's not what happens to somebody,
it's what they do as a result of it.
And that's the fucking light came on.
And I mean,
for years I would sit there and it took
me seven years to write the evolution of
a cro magnon and I would get to that
part of the story and I will lose my shit
and break down crying like
fucking uncontrollably
because of what happened to me
and my brothers.
So I just skipped over that part
and I would never address it.
But then,
you know,
he gave me the strength in a lot of ways
to be able to say, hey man, you got it.
He wrote in my book so I have his
book and he wrote to me, he goes,
John always write the truth.
And that's when I knew that that needed
to come out in the book to cleanse
myself. I've been two
years on crack, uh, 88,
88 to 90 crack pills, you know, uh,
doing whatever getting shot at
with fucking Ar 15 is Robin deals.
I had a tos or now it was chaos
at a time kill on site. I was,
I was a fucking maniac
because I just didn't care.
I actually kind of wish subconsciously
to somebody would put a fucking bullet in
me when doing crack. A lot
of people get molested. Yeah.
They almost act out to the point where
they want someone else to do it for them
cause they don't want to. Here I was
definitely in a lot of ways that's,
that's what I was doing.
But when I took his,
when that seminar helped me so much,
cause it's really like,
he's really like a fucking a guru in
a teacher. Man. The man is amazing.
If you ever get a chance to take the
Robert McKee story seminar to three day
seminar, I took it twice, then he
does workshops, but the story seminar,
I just walked out of there after the third
day is 10 hours a day and you're just
like, you're fucking,
you're, you're like speeches.
Like what the fuck did I just
experience? It's incredible. And,
and that gave me, uh, the power to,
to go and tell my story the right way
and the amount of emails of people that I
received that will like, Yo,
that shit was done to me.
Thank you for having the courage to
tell the story. And um, you know,
I just kept writing after that. So
even the meat is for pussies. Uh,
book was, you know, if you read it,
it's tongue in cheek. I'm not calling.
There's a lot of dudes that eat meat
that could kick the shit out of me.
I'm not saying,
what I'm saying is if you continue to
lead a sanitary lifestyle and you eat this
fucked up food that's out there,
that they're putting out there,
that they're knowingly putting out there
to fucking poison you because they're
tied in with the pharmaceutical companies.
It's a racket. It's it. It's not,
a conspiracy has been proven
that this is what they're doing.
You will become a pussy dependent
on the pharmaceutical companies.